SNOQUALMIE CASINO PORTS BOOK
JOHANSSON TURNED OUT THAT TIME.
RIGHT OFF THE GOALP HAYDN
FLEURY, WHO STAYS IN THE LINEUP
AFTER PLAYING FRIDAY NIGHT
AGAINST ST.ICKED OUT.
THEY SCORE ON THE CAROM.
SAM BENNETTGRUBAUER'S
PAD.
I BELIEVE THAT HIT SOUCY'S SKATE
GOING INTO THE NET. FOR GOURDE..
HE HELP FROM ONE GOALPOST SO
FAR.
ANTHONY DUCLCLNG BY EBERLE.
GAINS THE ZONE.
PULLS UP A BIT.
FOR GEEKIE.NFOL.
SECOND PERIOD OF THE LONG
CHANGE.
EKBLAD ISGIORDANO, GOESNTO THAT
AREA AND IS ABLE TO JUS ONE-TIM.
HE SCORES!
BLISTERINGNG ONE-TIMER UP OVER
THE SHOULDER.
YOU
GOAL.
APPLETON.
OFF
EKBLAD WALKS THE LINE.
JONATHAN HUBERDEAU WITH A SHOT.
HE SCORES. GET IT
HUBERDEAU.
A QUICK RELEASE ACROSS.
BARKOV, SHOT.
THEY SCORE.
IT THAT IT GUYS
UP AND OVER GRUBAUER.
THURSDAY.
APPLETON.
SCORES!
THERE IT IS!
MASON APPLETON WITH
TWO-ON-ONE.
APPLETON WASTES NO TIME.
DOESN'T LOOK FOR THAT EXTRA
YES,LEKSANDER
BARKOV.
BROKEN UP.
PLAYED INSIDE THEUT.
1:45 LEFT.TS A GOOD
LARSSON GETS AFTER IT.
THEY
DUCLAIR DOES THE RIGHT THING.
HEAYS NICE WHEN YOU
CAN SKATE THE PUCK PRETTY MUCH
ALL THE WAY IN TO THE EMPTY N